uh your office is all the way down at  the end you have your own  attached bathroom by the way oh um  here's one of our best researchers dick  hey uh hello there  what's up dude glad to see there's  another brother in this stunning place  so um this is um gonna be your assistant  genevieve  genevieve um what is this it's the  shining man  all black people have the shine you  never shine with another black person  before  no i grew up in a white neighborhood and  then went to dartmouth  i've met other black people before but  not like this you got to get  shined at by another black person first  and then you get it  it's kind of like facebook  what up dudes